here are the nominees for achievement in
makeup and hairstyling Dallas buyers
club a drizzly and Robin Matthews
jackass presents bad grandpa Stephen
Prouty The Lone Ranger
Joel Hollow and Gloria pass crocosmia
and the Oscar goes to Dallas buyers club
differently a lot of Matthew
this is the first Oscar for a brutally
and Robin Matthew
thank you so much to the Academy my
goodness you all fought for the hair and
makeup of this film you fought for it
and you've fulfilled every dream we've
ever had to our friends and family thank
you
it's a Matthew McConaughey and Jared
Leto thank you so much for letting us
transform and torture you through a
million bazillion my hair makeup changes
of the day and for your support with our
makeup
Sean Mark ballet you are a visionary you
are so amazing and thank you for
choosing two of us to take this crazy
journey with you and finally for all the
victims of AIDS we are so lucky and
blessed to be able to bring your story
to the forefront of the younger
generation today that doesn't understand
AIDS 85 we're very blessed thank you
thank you
hello Alex Nathan